[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and toss a coin to your
YouTuber because we're breaking down The
Witcher season three part one is just
released on Netflix and with part two
around the corner we have a lot to talk
about
yep it's not all As It Seems and for the
first part of the video I want to go
through what we learned come the end of
episode 5 adapting part of the Blood of
Elves in time of contempt it does kind
of feel like they split this season
after the fact rather than them having a
compelling clip hanger to close on now
originally the villain was thought to be
struggable but we learn in the finale
that that's not the case we end with
Jennifer and geralt finally working it
out and it turns out it was bilge Ford's
all along yet he was behind the missing
novices experiments book stealing and so
on what he wants is for Siri to help an
actor's plan and this has been theorized
to banish the elves for good this makes
sense as according to Francesca's
discussion of the prophecy the child of
Elder blood will take the elves to
safety The Village thoughts May simply
want to use her to take them out for
good which we'll discuss more about as
we get further into the video now for
much of the last season and this one
we've had the underlying mystery of
whosome the characters are working for
and also who's been the person that's
been corrupting the portals he would
have got away with it too if it hadn't
been for those men meddling witch guys
and Village forts like most Villages
can't stop giving himself away he has to
give a monologue and explain his entire
plan and he basically turns into a
must-hash twirling villain and while
season 2 and 3 largely moved away from
the mixed up timeline scenes into a
linear story The Writers sort of bring
this back but the finale to tell the
party before the conclave during the
groundhog day yennefer and geralt slowly
work out they accuse the wrong guy in
between doing a bit of her and it was
quite an interesting way to figure out
who was who at one point Village
Schwartz talks to geralt about a
painting which shows Jam Becker and the
first landing this is the first time the
humans landed where the northern
kingdoms are now and we know from the
history that they started take over the
side of the first lining was where
yenefo was taken and this combined with
the fact that tisay's necklace was given
to her by Village forts is made of the
same material as Lydia's necklace as we
know Lydia has been employing Ryan's all
this time but the person behind it all
was indeed belchfort however there's
much more to this season than simply
that ending as we close out with Dykstra
holding girl that knife point we will
discuss that later on in the video but
for the next part I want to kind of
discuss what the state of the show's in
now as I'm sure many of you know this
will be the final one for Henry Cavill
who's departing the series after he
basically got fed up of the writers not
sticking to the law the announcement
came out shortly after he appeared as
Superman at the end of Black Adam but we
all know after the dceu hit rock bottom
that things have been thrown out in a
Flash
feel really bad for the guy as he seemed
really excited for Man of Steel too but
from what I've heard he would have left
this either way due to how they were
handling the material Henry will be
heading up Warhammer 40K which if you've
seen interviews you know he's totally
obsessed with so let's talk about what
you guys personally geek out about Henry
let's start with you uh specifically
which universe or just I mean just say
oh my goodness
I was like how much time do we have
listen I'll stay here all day listening
ruling out The Witcher yeah
um I mean the easy answer is um
Warhammer 40 000 that is my my jab
um I have been into it since I was 10.
what's your army at the moment uh
custodies ah yeah I'm going I'm going
necrons next week okay all right cool
yes were you into this before or let's
just assume that anything nerdy I've
been doing for a good thing oh wow we
could talk for hours yeah so yeah this
is that's my jam and that's the stuff I
do in my free time that's amazing now
this show in its prequel have been
chastised by fans of the source material
and I have to admit I think this has
been the worst season it's difficult to
fully judge it because we only have the
first half but I think it dragged out
the mystery and also felt very very
repetitive not just the party but I felt
like I was at the party myself with lots
of things being what I've seen before
and I can totally understand his
departure Henry's spoken about how he's
a true guardian of the law when it comes
to Witcher in Superman and in regards to
this he's been very open
it's funny uh I I I try not to focus on
the pressure aspect of it
um I make it more of a personal mission
myself rather than a pressure aspect
whether it be Superman whether it be the
Witcher whether it be Sherlock Holmes
I'm not feeling the external pressure
it's more about me certainly when it
comes to Superman and The Witcher those
are characters I grew up with and and I
love and I really really want to
represent in the most
Source accurate way possible and that
for me was a was a massive thing and and
still is a massive thing and uh when it
comes to when it comes to Sherlock
Holmes I wasn't reading the books of
Sherlock Holmes necessarily and so I
managed to absolve myself of of this
this Duty which I put on myself which is
being a law loyalist and it's always
about the details and it's always I'm
the most annoying guy on set because I'm
saying um excuse me you do realize that
this should be happening and they
wouldn't do that and you haven't read
this then that means this would be
impossible and everyone's just going
Henry just shut up and do the thing and
I'm like I don't want to do the thing
because because he wouldn't he wouldn't
do it this way and he he can do this now
with this in mind right about it Mayo
said I've been on shows namely Witcher
where some of the writers were not fans
or actively dislike the books and games
even actively mocking The Source
material it's a recipe for disaster and
bad morale banham is a litmus test
checks Egos and makes all the long
nights worth it you have to respect the
work before you you're allowed to add to
its Legacy now because of this people
have presumed that Henry clash with the
writers who've been very open that they
dislike the source material seems like
the best people for the job Netflix get
someone who doesn't like it to write it
and in the end there's been lots of
rumors flying around Henry was accused
of creating a toxic attitude unset and
trying to overrule a showrunner during
season two and three apparently he
created an alliance with another writer
who was also a gamer and fan of the law
either way we know the outcome of it now
and I was surprised that they announced
a new actor as quickly as they did that
will see Liam Hemsworth stepping into
the show I know I like the guy it wasn't
that well received I think the
showrunners could probably sense things
were coming to an end unless they've
filmed seasons four and five back to
back which I think spells things out
Netflix were likely Gonna Cancel them if
the next season doesn't pop off and thus
they've shot them concurrently to ensure
they tell their story and the producers
have explained that there's a Flawless
plan to switch up the geralt actors and
supposedly they're gonna get very meta
considering that the books go in very
very well places then it could actually
turn out to be pretty cool and I think
most people will probably return to see
how it plays out now back to the plot of
season three and the other plot threads
at dangle and it mainly focuses on
keeping Siri safe whilst they're on the
Run he spells off the back of the events
of season two which is where we learn
the Emperor of nilf God was actually
Siri's father while the emperor in the
Box was searching for sorry to take
control of Centralia we did not find out
that he was indeed her dad until right
at the end most factions in our
searching for Siri including Francesca
in the northern kingdoms which each want
her for their own reasons the NF is
aiming to keep a safe by taking her to a
school to train her powers but
eventually she ends up splintering as
Siri resents the Mages now it's
important to remember that some believe
Siri to be the subject of Ethan's
prophecy that foretold the world ending
in a gigantic blizzard this would leave
only the elves surviving and they'd then
be saved by the child of the Elder blood
now we discovered that she did did
indeed have Elder blood as she's the
descendant of a character known as Laura
Doran this is an Elven sorceress that
was part of an experiment to enhance
magical powers who fell in love with a
human Mage now while the northern
kingdoms wanted to control Centralia
Francesca wanted to guide the elves into
a new Homeland the source of Village
thoughts who as we will learn once air
so that he can use her power to gain
even more power only books it's
prophesies the child Siri has will be
the most powerful magical user in the
world and Bill Schwartz wants to help
make that child and the final players
who probably won't make their move for a
while as the wild Hunt who we saw in the
last season and here in episode 3. in
which your blood origin we so well the
origin of the wild Hunt which formed
such a big part of the third Witcher
game which are unofficial sequels to the
book I mean obviously the game's title
is The Witcher 3 wild Hunt so you're
gonna get The Witcher going up against
the wildhood spoiler alert
and we also saw the wild Hunt in season
2 and you might remember they asked Siri
to join them and stand by their side
wild Hunt or their leader erode wants to
use serious power to invade other worlds
as they can only bring a small conjun
across from where they're at blood
Origins show the conjunction of the
Spears in very very simple terms which
was a colliding of realities that led to
humans on this world that prequel show
also showed Eridan and much of the time
before the conjunction of spheres with
him being a military leader who became
trapped in another world yep Multiverse
baby and Siri does eventually travel
across these worlds which even leads to
the world of cyberpunk the world where
Eridan couldn't find you what was it
like you wouldn't believe me if I told
you
try me
people there had metal in their heads
waged war from a distance using things
similar to megascopes and there were no
horses everyone had their own flying
ship instead Siri stop fooling around
told you you wouldn't believe me
we should have stayed though now the
show took some very very big Liberties
as in the book Aaron could travel across
worlds and in those we had him leading
the red riders in the world he would
steal people to use as slaves and he
discovered the main witchy World along
with all the others however the
conjunction trapped them on another
world and eventually they use Mages to
travel to the other ones in the end
though they could only bring across the
red Riders and the people saw these red
Riders and then called them the wild
Hunt they appeared like spectral ghosts
riding across the Plains and you can
kind of see how it all came into this
Legend and they're sort of like ring
wraiths which of course made a big
impact in Lord of the Rings however the
prequel showers the conjunction as a
result of the evil Mage Balor this was
him wanting to take power from the other
worlds which also brought into play
things known as the monoliths the
monoliths which are only in the show who
acted as a conduit and when one was
destroyed it tore the fabric of Worlds
this brought humans and monsters into
the main one and it's all sort of
multiversal stuff of and worlds
colliding and this sent the character
Eridan to another world and we saw him
putting on a mask which is his wild Hunt
armor now Baylor a new character for the
blood origin show is also banished to
another world but the snow and ice from
the end of the world prophecies shown
here is sentient in the boxing games
this was an upcoming Ice Age predicted
by iflin and it's lighter thought
someone with elder blood can open up
portals and this can basically take
people off Earth until the ice is melted
the white Frost has consumed many many
worlds but eventually this gets stopped
in The Witcher 3 the wild Hunt now over
time Eridan will no doubt form the
show's version of the wild Hunt and
eventually try and take Siri and her
powers all the while Avalanche and
ancient Elf character who appears later
in the books hunted for Siri and he was
also trying to avert the crisis like the
wild Hunt he will appear more later down
the line as World Schwartz plan to use a
book of monoliths becomes further
expanded on and the wild Hunt are
mentioned briefly by the boat captain
who alluded to their people stealing
aways but for for now they just teased
as the end game and the profits of Doom
now with all that being said we may have
gotten a bit ahead of ourselves can you
tell that I just played Witcher 3 and
they're going back to season three it
mainly focuses on all the major players
eventually ending up at the conclave
this is requested by Jennifer bring all
the Mages together and this is so they
can unite against nilf God at the end of
the last season tisay and the northern
monarchs wanted to put a price on Siri's
head so that Dykstra couldn't get her
and marry her off to vizimir this is
Sarah Danier could control sintra and
rodania plays a major role in these
episodes even if I've just pronounced
the name wrong now as Dykstra and
Philippa aim to keep control and vizimir
Dykstra wants to make a play for sintra
by taking Siri even go so far as to kill
the wife of king vizimir after he broke
a deal with nilfgaard without involving
him sensing their power waning the pair
after and blamed it on nilf gods and at
their plans then became unaffected
enlisted in the plan is radovid who in
the books became king after vizimir was
killed you'll know that would be the
most controversial book change with the
hardcore fans and hear their brothers
that have been aged up considerably he
starts a flirtationship with Jessica
partly out of Attraction however he also
wants to use his connection to geralt to
help find Siri the pair case when he
should be looking after her and we will
see how this plays out later down the
line now like I said he's remarkably
different from the source material and
while those most of his later Reign
takes place in The Witcher games the
show seems to be changing things up once
again now throughout the season and
final episode much is made of geralt's
neutrality he doesn't play the political
games as he simply wants to keep Siri
safe but unfortunately he's beset at all
sides this is much like the books and
the games where they ultimately want you
to choose and it's going to decide
whether series used for Elder blood or
her Regal lineage and extra grabs girl
whilst he's about to confront belge
Forts and from here we go to Black
closing it all out both Tris and istrid
managed to work out that something's
going on as students with album blow
blood are going missing they theorize
that Village fort's going to use the
book of monoliths to banish the elves
for GERD and they're left by The
Season's end investigating the rug Mage
now what village Schwartz is doing is
that he's been conducting experiments to
try and clone Siri who's been left by
geralt in the books an imposter Surrey
was used by the emperor and this was a
way to bring sintra into the Empire yep
even The Witcher isn't safe from any
sort of incest now your big question is
likely what happened after geralt was
kind of captured at the end well in the
book Tower of contempt where much of the
Season takes its story from after the
Cliffhanger Dykstra and Philippa use his
moment to wipe out supporters of
nilfgaard the meeting will lead to An
Almighty Showdown which is presumably
what's going to happen as we wrap up
this whole season now we know in the
books of course that he does confront
bilge Fort once more only for geralt to
then be defeated Siri escapes and in the
Yankee here and geralt team up and they
go and try and track her down however
scoyatel also at us they say squirrel
was a variation so I'll say it will go
with squirrel however a squirrel also
attacks along with Ryan zinke here due
to Alliance that they have with nilf God
in the show we saw kahir being sent to
Francesca to give him an order as part
of an alliance this will prove to be
fruitful later on in the story and
probably pay off in The Season's second
half akihir finally fell back in a favor
with the emperor by bringing stability
to Francesca solves by removing Robbie
ammo's Gallatin this presumably leads to
no resistance to an elf God and after an
attack on The Enclave they try and grab
Siri essentially the next few episodes
will follow the second half of the book
time of contempt and the war will break
out once more with each side having
their own plans in the book geralt
stumble across this coup set up by
Philippa and Dykstra and was later
defeated by Village forts before the
Mage escaped he tried a portal away with
Siri before Siri disappears heals a
unicorn and joins it with Refugee
Bandits this then allows the lodge of
sorceress to be created and I'm guessing
that's where we're all gonna be heading
in the end geralt is saved by Trace but
how much they cover next time remains to
be seen now there are three more
episodes left to come on July 27th which
should wrap up this story and set the
stage William Hemsworth the first five
episodes to me were pretty mad and I
can't help but feel like the show has
lost its magic the standouts were geralt
and Siri working together with the
investigation into Ryan's Master feeling
rather drawn out leading to a lackluster
Cliffhanger speaking to the verge the
producer Steve gorb said they were
inspired by stranger things and he said
in a streaming World Cliffhangers don't
really exist because you're hitting play
right after an episode ends you don't
get the satisfaction of the anticipation
and discussion and shedding online so we
wanted to give that to the fans and the
story was there for us to do it and
while I appreciate them as the binge
watch model has been shown up heavily by
weekly releases such as the boys it
feels rather flat and you can just read
what happens in the books unlike
stranger things while I'm not too much a
fan of some of the changes though I do
think there were some good bits but
overall I didn't feel it was that
memorable I'll see how the second half
goes but judging by this part alone I
have to say that I felt slightly
disappointed either way I will be back
next time and make sure you comment
below giving us your thoughts and
feelings on the show if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week we
also have our merch store over at
xeroedition.com which sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
who just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction one so if you want to
support the channel and get some cool
merch out of it then definitely head
over there right after this by the way
huge thank you for staying through the
video I've been poor and I'll see you
next time you take care peace
[Music]